isn't always easy in another country
buses and trains are cheap and good for
the environment but not always very
comfortable and in some places they
might not be so safe
taxis are expensive and rental cars have
another problem you have to park them
somewhere
in big cities like los angeles and new
york parking fees are extremely high
making car rental even more expensive
we're in san francisco to test an app
that's already been a success in germany
it's called drive now
the app shows you where the nearest
available car is and how long it takes
to walk there you can reserve it by
tapping an icon then go to the car
unlock it get in and drive away time to
see if this german app works in america
it's a few minutes walk to the car
reinhold has reserved eight minutes
later it's right there the bmw 1 series
active e
you hold up the customer card to the
reader and then the journey begins the
first 30 minutes cost 12
each additional minute is 32 cents a
full day costs 60 dollars
compared to a taxi uh drive now is very
affordable so a trip from downtown san
francisco to the airport would cost half
as much
in a drive now car as it would cost in a
taxi
we take advantage of the competitive
price to do a bit of sightseeing and the
160 kilometer range of the active e is
more than enough the electric motor uses
more power going uphill but recuperates
it going downhill
like on the famous lombard street
but what if we want to park the car
there's a special app called park now
he says the app doesn't just give you
the address where the car is parked but
also tells you how to get there and
that's better than certain others that
only list the address and then you
discover the entrance is at the back of
the building on a different street where
others are already looking for a parking
space that takes a lot of time and is
also bad for the environment
we can not only find parking spaces with
the app we can also reserve them
directly just by tapping an icon
parking is definitely a pain point that
everybody speaks to in san francisco and
unfortunately there has been no solution
because the parking industry has not
been able to create a marketplace
so park now when it came onto the scene
has really created an opportunity to
create a marketplace where the consumer
can now have visibility to the parking
which is usually
opaque by the private operator and now
with the onset of our new partners we
also provide the on-street parking as
well as the off-street parking
but it's not time to park yet we instead
take a trip across the golden gate
bridge to the countryside on the other
side of san francisco bay the daily rate
of 60 dollars includes 300 kilometers
and the battery still has plenty of
charge
says the bmw active e drives like a
normal car the recuperative braking
might take some getting used to it first
but you'll soon be happy to see each
time it adds a kilometer to the car's
range the drive now app also works
without any problems you just open it up
find a car book it unlock it use it stop
it lock it and that's all even in
another country
in iceland